(applause)
I love your outfit.
You know?
No big deal, just on "The Drew Barrymore Show".
Try to show off a little bit.
I love your book.
How did you first get
into the meat industry, Loreal?
Oh, Drew, I've been cooking my whole life.
I'm 33 now, started when I was 15.
My grandma had a huge impact on me growing up.
So I've been cooking a long time.
And part of being a chef was they never really touched
on the meat industry, fabrication artists, and cuts.
So I had an opportunity to take a job years ago
and I can't believe all the doors that opened for me.
Now, like, talk about your experience.
Like you're a woman, it's a male dominated field,
you wanted to get into artisan cuts.
How did that all come about?
Well, I never noticed in the midst
of doing things that are mostly known
as male traits that I was a woman doing them.
Like as a chef, I'm constantly surrounded by dudes.
I love to ride motorcycles.
I play music.
So I guess I just like dude stuff
and I like to wear lipstick.
So I never really noticed
I wasn't like where I was supposed to be, you know.
I really relate to that because I feel
like I have a tomboy alive inside of me,
but I guess I'm inherently a girl, and I love women.
So I really appreciate everything you just said.
I feel the same way.
Well, being, being in television too,
I realized the importance
of having a thick skin and a pretty face.
You know what I'm saying?
You got to kind of have it all, you know.
Okay, Loreal. Why is that
not on every tee shirt and billboard?
And you do have to have a tough skin, you know.
You really do.
I had to hear things all the time that are hard to hear
and I'm glad that we can handle it.
And what is your message
for young girls who may want to become butchers
themselves one day and be artisanal about the approach?
Well, my biggest thing is stay hungry
and don't not reach out to your homies.
There are tons of amazing, beautiful women
out there who want to, like, give you a leg up.
You know what I mean?
And I think a lot of times, as women,
years and years ago,
women didn't want to help other women out.
They didn't necessarily want to give them pointers
or let them know how they got to be
where they are, being successful.
And like, those things are done.
Like I love just celebrating women in general.
Like if you look good and I see you
on the street, I'ma tell you, "You look beautiful"
and like, we need more energy out there.
So these women just need to get on the Internet,
type in, there's tons of, there's tons of groups
you can join.
Like there's no excuse for the internet.
You know what again, I'm gonna agree with you,
Loreal, because when we did "Charlie's Angels",
people were like, "Are the girls going to be
cat fighting?"
And I was like, no, they're gonna be best friends,
lift each other up,
like talk about dating while they're kicking butt.
Right?
And you know, cat fights used to be the standard
and now I think women supporting women is the standard.
I'm so glad to see that.
I really want to ask you a question that I
found really important.
What are your three money saving tips
when it comes to buying meat?
Well, first off, buy in bulk.
You can save a lot of money
when you buy bigger pieces of meat.
And when you shop within an amazing butcher shop
they're going to cut it up for you,
any way that you want.
Secondly, don't be afraid to shop
for those tougher cuts of meat.
A lot of times we're going to be less expensive
and they are some of the most beautiful cuts
of meat at the end of the day,
by the time they get to the table.
For example, before mignon, it's a chuck roast.
It's a tough and extensive cut.
And last but not least, be nice.
Talk to your butchers,
get a relationship with them,
ask them how they are,
bring them a cup of coffee because we'll hook you up.
A little bit of kindness seriously goes
a super long way.
Ugh. Loreal, I just love everything you are saying.
(upbeat music)